I'm going to show you part 1 in 2 I hope
you sort of have made some progress if
not completed one or two the main meal
is parts 3 & 4 but you can't really
progress through 3 & 4 until you've got
one and through there okay so I'm just
going to show you the first two plants
show you the way I approach it and then
I will let you us again to have to spend
some more time on the 3 & 4 ok so just
look up with me just look up even if
you've finished 1 & 2 I want you to see
the way I have approached it because
this is almost it's almost a time game
in some ways like the circle geometry
question is frequently toward the end of
the paper and we got window like you can
just pour all this time into a circular
geometry question and waste your time
for the rest of the paper ok so just as
a general note when you've got reading
time wait you got reading time as you're
going through and you see this diagram
okay if the answer jumps out at you
that's great when you get to this
question go ahead and do it if the
answer does not jump out at you in 10
seconds it's the last question you
should do okay because if it's not there
in 10 seconds you could spend 10 minutes
on this and make no progress and you
don't have that time to waste
okay so if you see quickly go for it if
not put it to one side let's have a look
at the first two parts what they asked
at the beginning is it doesn't turn to a
psychic a circulatory question just yet
they talked about similar triangles okay
so we did this diagram you can see I've
got this circle in place here I've put
the circle in because I know I'm going
to get a circle eventually I put it in
red to indicate I don't actually do that
yet so I'm not going to use any of its
properties for part one I'll only be
able to use them after pot - okay right
so first let's just focus on these
triangles they talked asked to look at
ABC that's the big triangle out here and
ad e AE D which is this little one just
sort of on the outside okay so to help
me what I've done is I've redrawn the
two triangles because they're
overlapping each other right when
they're overlapping my brain just gets
confused and I can't see like which way
and they're supposed to be oriented to
her
I have trouble matching up which side
like which ones correspond because they
sort of on top of each other I think
that's confusing so that's why I've
drawn these guys you can draw them nice
and roughly when I have a look
I pointed out to somebody before these
are our four tests for Cochran's these
are four tests for close ones it's a
little-known fact which is a good salmon
that there are four tests for similarity
which correspond exactly to these right
I've put them in order of kind of sides
all sides two sides one side this is for
congruence each of these tests has a
version facility so for example SSS what
would that mean for similar triangles
all sides all three sides correspond to
and are in proportion to the other sides
in the bigger or smaller triangle right
this one here you're going to have two
sides that are proportion instead of
which appears I should say and they
donate the angle that's in the middle
we'll really call that what again
well we rather than say in the middle we
have a special word for it we call it
the included angle maybe you've got this
one that'll become equiangular and so on
right now you have a look at the data
that you've got you have to rule out
some of them right some of them are very
easy to rule out for instance RHS is
irrelevant right why no right angles at
least none that I know about in fact I'm
pretty sure they can't because that does
look very tight Bogoria to me so that's
out
what about sss can I use that I can't
use that because if you have a look I've
got all three sides in the little
triangle but I do not have all three
sides in the three triangles so that's
out I've already ruled these with that
so you can see like I know people
looking at a secretory question or a
geometry question in general and you
just know so much to do mercury now you
have to choose so I'm trying to like it
multiple choice you know when you look
at four answers and some of them are
just ridiculous right so get them out of
the way first and that will make this
easy to do now I have to choose between
to have a look which is the better
choice I think I say S is the better
choice right because look I've got quite
a few sides quite a few and I don't I
don't know many angles at all okay so
now that I've got I settled which
direction I'm going to go in now I'm
ready to redraw my diagram with the
relevant information highlighted okay
so first I've got a de I've got that in
the orientation that's there and what
I've done is I've covered the side so I
can see which ones correspond to
so I've got let's say three three four
here now when you have a look you can
see it's sort of upside down from the
other one right can you see it's upside
down this happens frequently because
these lines are not parallel to each
other then this guy here a is going to
correspond to a B C now that might not
be really obvious to you but what's that
put in the numbers I hope you'll see a B
is how long it's a it's on longer side
right and then AC is six six six AC it's
the shortest side ah now you can see
there's a corresponding pair there's a
cursed one you care
looking good I need one last fact again
remember what the last fact is yeah I
need that England and need the included
angle right edit just so happens that
this angle is in fact common okay so I'm
pretty much done I'm not gonna write all
that but I would say here's my structure
in this triangle in that triangle the
first thing I start with is the a book
okay I'm gonna say these the same movies
comment let's all write that down and
then I'll say okay I've got a matchup
corresponding sides now please know the
site I'm matching up are the
corresponding sides even the different
triangles it's not these two these are
not corresponding sides these are
corresponding sides that's why I've done
them at the same column so I'm going to
go 3 over 6 is 1/2 so that's one ratio
and then I'm going to go 4 over 8 that's
1/2 so now they're equal this is worth
writing down there are very long waist
long in them
obtuse ways of saying this so and I
think this is the shortest one I've ever
encountered that you've got sides right
and um another way of like when you say
angle is included that's talking about
the able but if you turn it besides you
say the sides up about that angle that
means on both sides
okay so sides about equal angles just
happens to be one angle in this case but
you get the idea
sides about equal angles are in
proportionate seven words
okay I feel it's pretty concise come in
grabs it okay
so very good we've got to similarly now
ready to make this is circle geography
question okay no Reba you just proved
that these triangles are similar
okay so I've got that in the back of
mine they're probably gonna want me to
use that in some way I want to show that
this guy over here
Bede see is cycling okay it's cycling
now we actually really don't know that
maybe think it's about safely calculate
there's only a very small number of
properties that I can appeal to everyone
have told me just throw out properties
of cyclic why could go straight to the
one that I'm gonna do is I'm gonna use
that okay there's an easier one that
usually comes to mind most people most
people the first property that comes to
mind the main property for cyclic courts
is that opposite angles things are
supplementary okay I couldn't use that
but there's a quicker way if you've got
like alpha right and 180 minus alpha
then you've got an angle of a straight
line here right so that makes this alpha
and that's a whole other property of
it's better described he's outside the
cyclic quad so we call it an exterior
angle I'm gonna highlight it this is
really important to mention this angle
right so this angle over here we're just
not two lines because I'm really used to
it I'll color I do this angular here is
the exterior angle of the sacre-coeur
I'm after right if only I had some way
to prove that would it's equal to this
guy oh wait I do right look look at my
similar triangles that I just drew I'm a
IDI that's what he'll write and this
angle I'm he ABC AHA it corresponds he
did bareheaded correspond Eliza Nelson
well okay so from platoon I'm gonna say
angle AED is equal to angle ABC reason
car corresponding what correspond the
angles in similar triangles
are equal therefore next line therefore
big Dec is a cyclic coordinate just say
it's cyclic because what what's the
property I'm taking your body job
exterior angle on this planet Colorado
is equal to though what is that in
relation the opposite interior angles
okay all right so you could say that
it's a it's a little trickier but it
works um that you've got the yeah yeah
what you've got here is the products of
the intersect one two and one two the
products of the if two cents on seekers
are equal
okay now the reason why that will take
you a little longer is number one the
reason is just like me to say number two
you then have to reason a little bit
about the fact that what does it mean
but these things are intercepts okay and
therefore move a be BD and DC are courts
from the circle because chords find an
intercept you're getting here and so
therefore this like ah yeah that's true
that's okay so you can go to the sides
path or you can go the angles path I
think most people see the angles first
but cycle work just like